¡Hola a todos! Bienvenidos a esta nueva explicación.
Hoy vamos a meternos de lleno en una cuenta atrás que, literalmente,
va a poner patas arriba el panorama empresarial en Chile.
Hablamos de la nueva Ley de Privacidad y Protección de Datos.
Vamos a desgranar toda esta normativa para entender, paso a paso,
cómo podemos proteger a las organizaciones frente a unos riesgos
que ya están a la vuelta de la esquina.
Para que nos hagamos una idea de la magnitud de este cambio,
quedaos con esta cifra.
20.000.
20.000 unidades tributarias mensuales.
Esa es la multa máxima por infracciones gravísimas bajo esta nueva legislación.
O sea, estamos hablando de sanciones que superan los 1.000 millones de pesos chilenos.
Es una barbaridad.
Es un nivel de castigo sin precedentes que deja clarísimo
que con esto de verdad no se juega.
A ver, profundicemos un poco más en esto.
Esta sanción tan enorme viene con la nueva Ley 21.719,
que entra en pleno vigor el 1 de diciembre de 2026.
Básicamente, tenemos un reloj en cuenta regresiva haciendo tic-tac.
Las empresas no pueden, o más bien no deben,
esperar hasta el último trimestre de 2026 para ponerse las pilas.
Es absolutamente crucial tener todo el sistema de cumplimiento operativo mucho antes,
porque la nueva Agencia de Protección de Datos Personales,
la famosa APDP, va a estar ahí lista para fiscalizar desde el minuto uno.
Bueno, nuestra hoja de ruta para hoy es súper clara.
Empezaremos viendo el nuevo estándar de privacidad.
Luego pasaremos a los DPAs y el artículo 15bis.
El tercer punto serán las transferencias,
las transferencias transfronterizas.
Después hablaremos del riesgo de la IA en la sombra
y cerraremos con la parte de gobernanza.
Comprender estos cinco pilares nos va a evitar verdaderos desastres,
tanto financieros como reputacionales.
Así que venga, vamos con el primer punto.
El nuevo estándar de privacidad.
El contraste entre lo que había y lo que viene es abismal.
Es como el día en la noche.
Fijaos, la antigua ley de 1999 permitía, de forma bastante laxa,
transmitir datos a terceros.
No tenía restricciones reales para sacar datos fuera del país.
Y bueno,
las multas eran mínimas.
Pero la nueva ley 21.719 cambia las reglas del juego por completo.
Básicamente alinea a Chile con el Reglamento General de Protección de Datos Europeo.
Y esto significa notificar brechas obligatoriamente,
tener bases legales súper estrictas que van mucho más allá del simple acepto
y sobre todo otorga un poder sancionador real a una autoridad central.
Pasamos al punto 2.
Los DPAs y el artículo 15bis.
Vale, ¿qué es un DPA?
O contrato de encargo de tratamiento.
Pues ahora mismo,
es un límite legal estricto y totalmente obligatorio.
Cualquier servicio externo, y digo cualquiera,
desde los típicos proveedores de la nube hasta la agencia de marketing digital
o la plataforma de recursos humanos necesita este contrato.
Ya no nos vale con un simple acuerdo de confidencialidad de toda la vida, no.
Ahora hay que detallar exactamente qué datos se procesan,
para qué y bajo qué medidas de seguridad súper rigurosas va a operar ese tercero.
Las zonas grises legales sencillamente desaparecen.
Y esto ilustra a la perfección lo rigurosa que es la nueva ley.
El artículo 15bis establece algo llamado responsabilidad solidaria.
A ver, en la práctica, esto significa que si una empresa contrata a un proveedor de software
y resulta que ese proveedor subcontrata a otro que tiene una fuga de datos,
la empresa original sigue siendo responsable, tal cual.
No vale lavarse las manos y echarle la culpa al proveedor.
Toda esta cadena de custodia de la información va a exigir una vigilancia absoluta
y, por supuesto, muy bien documentada.
Entonces, para evitar problemas con la nueva agencia fiscalizadora,
hay unos elementos clave que todo DPA tiene que incluir sí o sí.
Hay que dejar por escrito el objeto del mandato, su duración exacta, la finalidad
y qué tipo de datos y personas están implicadas.
Y ojo a esto, que es vital.
Tiene que haber reglas clarísimas de autorización por si el proveedor quiere usar subprocesadores.
Si nos saltamos alguno de estos puntos, el contrato, sintiéndolo mucho, es papel mojado ante la ley.
Vamos a por el tercer pilar.
Las transferencias transfronterizas de datos.
Aquí la cosa se pone seria.
Porque solo hay tres vías legales para que los datos personales salgan de Chile.
Primera opción, enviarlos a países con un nivel adecuado de protección.
Es decir, países que ya están preaprobados porque tienen unos estándares de privacidad altísimos.
Segunda opción, si el país de destino no tiene ese estatus,
las partes tienen que firmar cláusulas contractuales tipo.
Esto es para garantizar legalmente que los datos van a estar seguros allí.
Y la tercera, pensada sobre todo para las multinacionales,
es usar normas corporativas vinculantes que vienen a ser políticas internas súper estrictas a nivel global.
Si exportamos datos y no usamos uno de estos tres mecanismos, es una infracción inmediata.
Sin más.
Pasamos ahora al punto 4.
Y este es interesantísimo.
El riesgo de la IA en la sombra, o Shadow AI,
el Shadow AI, o la inteligencia artificial en la sombra,
es literalmente como poner una puerta blindada en la entrada de la oficina,
pero dejar la puerta de atrás abierta de par en par.
Hablamos del uso de inteligencias artificiales públicas por parte de los trabajadores
sin que el Departamento de Informática lo sepa.
Es una fuga invisible.
Imaginemos a un empleado que, con toda su buena intención,
mete datos de clientes en una IA pública para que le hagan un informe rápido.
Sin darse cuenta, está subiendo datos personales a servidores externos sin ningún control,
sin contratos de EPA y, por tanto, saltándose la ley a la torera.
Y ojo a la magnitud del problema porque es para preocuparse.
Hoy en día, un 20% de las organizaciones ya ha sufrido alguna brecha de seguridad
que viene disminuyendo.
Y esto no pasa directamente de esta IA en la sombra.
Pensadlo bien, los datos personales que usamos para alimentar esos grandes modelos de lenguaje
se quedan ahí, pueden ser memorizados y terminar expuestos a cualquier otro usuario de Internet.
Esto no es ciencia ficción ni un riesgo teórico,
es algo que pasa a diario y es tremendamente peligroso.
Además, el impacto económico ya se ha calculado.
Y duele.
Cuando hay una brecha de datos por culpa de usar una inteligencia artificial sin autorización,
el coste se dispara.
Cuesta de media unos...
670.000 dólares extras si lo comparamos con una brecha normal.
Es un sobrecoste brutal que viene, pura y llanamente,
de no tener bajo control las herramientas tecnológicas que la gente usa en la oficina todos los días.
Así que el quid de la cuestión aquí es la falta de preparación, que es alarmante.
El 63% de las empresas que sufren estos incidentes no tienen ninguna política de gobernanza para la IA.
Es decir, van completamente a ciegas.
Si tenemos en cuenta que la nueva ley 21.719 castiga muy duramente
entrenar algoritmos con datos personales sin anonimizar o sin pedir permiso explícito,
no tener políticas de IA es comprar todas las papeletas para llevarse una multa enorme.
Y llegamos al último punto, el 5. Gobernanza y cumplimiento.
Vale, ¿cómo ponemos la casa en orden antes de diciembre de 2026?
Pues hay que actuar ya.
Y esta es la hoja de ruta.
Paso 1. Mapear todos los datos, haciendo un registro de actividades de tratamiento y evaluaciones de impacto.
Paso 2. Súper importante.
Firmar absolutamente todos los contratos de encargo de datos.
Y, por último, el 4. Aplicar los datos de la IA en el área de tratamiento, los famosos DPA, con los proveedores.
Paso 3. Poner límites claros y controles técnicos para usar la IA en la empresa,
cortando de raíz el riesgo de la IA en la sombra.
Y el paso 4 es integrar la privacidad desde el diseño en cualquier proyecto nuevo que se arranque.
Haciendo esto, pasamos de tener un riesgo legal a conseguir una ventaja competitiva brutal basada en la confianza.
Y bueno, para ir cerrando esta explicación, creo que merece la pena dejar una pregunta en el aire.
Si alguien en la oficina le pasa datos a una IA pública hoy,
¿cuáles son los datos de ese cliente mañana?
La privacidad ha dejado de ser algo opcional.
Es la infraestructura básica para sobrevivir en el mundo digital.
Así que ser proactivos con la Ley 21.719 no es solo tachar una casilla legal,
es el seguro de vida para el futuro.
Muchísimas gracias por acompañarnos a desenredar este escenario legal y tecnológico tan complejo, pero fascinante.